Er gilt als einer der größten Köpfe der
Physik: Der Nobelpreisträger Wolfgang Ernst
Pauli formulierte 1925 das nach ihm benannte
Pauli-Prinzip - eine quantentheoretische Erklärung
dafür, wie ein Atom aufgebaut ist.
Doch nicht nur das: Pauli sagte auch das Neutrino
in der Theorie voraus - und das 25 Jahre,
bevor es tatsächlich beobachtet werden konnte!
Und noch etwas sollte unvergessen bleiben:
der äußerst mysteriöse Pauli-Effekt.
Der Physiker war bekannt dafür, dass in seiner
Anwesenheit Experimente misslangen, Geräte
kaputt gingen und Maschinen zu Bruch gingen.
Teilweise bekam er deswegen sogar Labor-Verbot.
Wie kann das sein?!
Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos, abonniert den Kanal,
aktiviert die Glocke, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts. - herzlich willkommen!
Und danke für Euren super spannenden Themenvorschlag
aus unserer Community!
Wolfgang Pauli war nicht nur einer der bedeutendsten
Physiker des 20.
Jahrhunderts, sondern ganz sicher auch ein
schräger Vogel.
Schon mit 13 Jahren beschäftigte er sich
mit physikalischen Aufsätzen und bereits
drei Jahre nach seinem Abitur hatte er sein
Physikstudium mit dem Doktortitel abgeschlossen.
Selbst der große Albert Einstein bewunderte
Paulis Abhandlung über die Relativitätstheorie,
doch der hatte neben der Physik vor allem
eine Sache im Kopf: Party, Party und nochmal
Party.
Früh am Morgen fand man ihn meistens in der
Kneipe.
Der deutsche Physiker Max Born berichtete
später mal: “Ich erinnere mich, dass er
[...] mehr als einmal die Vorlesung um 11
Uhr verpasste."
In Hamburg wurde Pauli dann zum Professor.
Er selbst beschrieb das so: “Als ich nach
Hamburg kam, wechselte ich (...) direkt vom
Mineralwasser zum Champagner."
Alles aber kein Problem für seine Karriere
- schließlich sollte er im Jahr 1945 nicht
umsonst den Physik-Nobelpreis bekommen. 1924
befasste Pauli sich intensiv mit Molekülspektren
und erklärte diese mit einem inneren Drehimpuls
des Atomkerns - heute auch als Kernsspin bekannt.
Ein Jahr später postulierte Pauli dann eine
vierte Quantenzahl, die wir heute als Elektonenspin
kennen.
Damit erklärte er die Aufspaltung von Spektrallinien
im Magnetfeld.
Der Physiker entwickelte ein Ausschlussprinzip,
das heute als “Pauli-Prinzip” bezeichnet
wird.
Vereinfacht gesagt kann ein Elektron nicht
den Zustand annehmen, den ein anderes Elektron
bereits annimmt.
Zwei Teilchen gleicher Quantenzahlen können
sich also nicht am selben Ort aufhalten.
Dieses Prinzip erklärt auch. warum eine “magische”
Anzahl von Kernteilchen Elemente besonders
stabil macht bzw. dass Materie nicht einfach
so in sich zusammenfällt. 1930 kam dann Paulis
Vorhersage eines winzigen neutralen Elementarteilchens
hinzu, das die Energiebilanz beim Beta-Zerfall
wieder ausgleichen würde.
In einem Brief schrieb er dazu an seine Kolleginnen
und Kollegen: " ” Die meisten seiner Kollegen
taten seine Gedanken damals noch als Humbug
ab.
Hinzu kam, dass Pauli nicht besonders viel
wert auf Veröffentlichungen legte.
Neue Gedanken und Ideen schrieb er lieber
in Briefen..
Dazu Pauli: “Ich kann es mir leisten, nicht
zitiert zu werden”.
Bezüglich seiner Entdeckungen ergänzte der
Physiker dann auch, dass man sich die Suche
nach der Quantenzahl als auch nach dem von
ihm postulierten Elementarteilchen sparen
könne.
Beide waren seiner Ansicht nach nämlich keinesfalls
messbar.
Damit lag er aber falsch, denn nicht nur die
“Eigenart” von Elektronen, die wir heute
als Spin bezeichnen, konnten nachgewiesen
werden.
Auch die .spektakuläre Entdeckung des Neutrinos
folgte ganze 25 Jahre später.
In der Fachwelt war Pauli aber nicht nur wegen
seiner wissenschaftlichen Leistungen bekannt.
Er genoss einen ganz besonderen Ruf, denn
er galt als Forscher mit zwei linken Händen.
So heißt es, dass er beispielsweise rund
100 Fahrstunden brauchte, um die Führerscheinprüfung
zu schaffen.
Berüchtigt war der Physiker auch, weil seine
Anwesenheit in den Laboren dieser Welt zu
einem kuriosen Effekt führte: Sobald Pauli
in die Nähe eines Experimentes kam, funktionierte
dieses nicht mehr.
Aber nicht nur das: Auch Geräte und Maschinen
gingen kaputt.
Der Experimentalphysiker Otto Stern verbot
seinem Kollegen deswegen, einen Fuß in sein
Labor zu setzen.
Manche Physikerinnen und Physiker nannten
dieses Phänomen, das man auch als “Pauli-Effekt”
bezeichnet, im Scherz auch das “zweite Paulische
Ausschließungsprinzip”: “Es ist unmöglich,
dass sich Wolfgang Pauli und ein funktionierendes
Gerät im selben Raum befinden”.
Pauli selbst glaubte fest daran und nahm es
mit Humor.
Bei einer Sitzung der Deutschen Physikalischen
Gesellschaft fiel der Diaprojektor aus und
Pauli stand auf, um sich selbst und den “Pauli-Effekt”
voller Stolz zu präsentieren. 1950 befand
sich Pauli an der Princeton University: Hier
brannte der Teilchenbeschleuniger.
Auch der Vorfall in Göttingen ist unvergessen.
Hier ging ein wertvoller Apparat kaputt - und
das Forschungsteam vor Ort betonte, dass es
diesmal ja nicht an Pauli liegen könne.
Schließlich sei dieser ja zur fraglichen
Zeit nicht in der Nähe gewesen.
Doch dem war nicht so: Paulis Angaben zufolge
hat er wohl genau zu diesem Zeitpunkt bei
seiner Reise nach Kopenhagen einen kurzen
Stopp in Göttingen gehabt.
Und ein Beispiel belegt den Effekt, wie ich
finde am Eindrucksvollsten.
Der italienische Physiker Giuseppe Occhialini
wollte Pauli einen Streich spielen.
Er konstruierte einen „Pauli-Effekt“:
eine Hängelampe wurde so befestigt, dass
sie herunterfallen würde wenn Pauli eine
Tür öffnete.
Alles war präpariert und als Pauli eintrat
ging es natürlich schief.
Die lampe fiel nicht von der Decke.
Es ist und bleibt absolut mysteriös.
Auch wenn es viele Beispiele gibt und der
Pauli-Effekt auch oft dokumentiert wurde,
kann er wissenschaftlich gesehen nicht erklärt
werden.
Doch sogar Stephen Hawking schrieb später
darüber: “Böse Zungen behaupten, er brauche
sich nur in einer Stadt aufzuhalten, schon
gingen alle dort durchgeführten Experimente
schief.“
Aber wer weiß, vielleicht findet die Wissenschaft
irgendwann die Erklärung für solche Phänomene.
Denn es gibt sie ja tatsächlich.
Kennt ihr jemanden mit einem solchen phänomen,
wo etwas immer schief geht oder immer klappt?
Schreibt es in die Kommentare!
Nichts desto trotz: Wolfgang Pauli gilt als
einer der größten Köpfe der Wissenschaft:
Die Vorhersage des Neutrinos und die Formulierung
des Pauli-Prinzips gelten als Meilensteine
in der Physik.
Superschwere Elemente – Die Jagd nach neuer
Materie Anklicken, anschauen und den megacoolen
Kanal Doktor whatson unbedngt abonnieren.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!